your reputation precedes you thank you
sir it wasn't a compliment I got to meet
Tom Cruise For the First Time at Jimmy
Kimmel's house big group of comedy
writers and comics and actors and the
Rumor was going like you know Tom Cruise
is supposed to come by today and we're
like no he's not that's talking about
that's like saying Santa Claus is coming
like and Jimmy famously is a very big
prankster and not only does the doorbell
ring it is Tim Tom Cruise with his mom
so we got Tom Cruise and Mom Cruz and uh
he had seen Mad Men because he kind of
was like in a very Tom Cruise way like
very direct and intense and I love that
show so then you know cut to however
many years later God my phone rings and
I yeah hello it's my agent hey they you
know they're coming at you for uh they
want you to do a part in in the Top Gun
sequel I was like no this is there's
this is a no-brainer the answer is yes
you work out the details but the answer
is yes if this goes away You're All
Fired I'm sure it will be a big hit and
it was